[Music]
well developing now henderson police
on the scene of a deadly accident in
henderson this is at the roma hills
community right off roma hills drive
close to horizon ridge parkway that's
where we find eight news now reporter
madison kimbrough where she's got all
the information for us
madison
yes it's an extremely active scene i
want you to take a look behind me
we're here on roma hills drive in
henderson and investigators are still
out here this is what we know so far
around 12 30
a security guard from the roma hills
gated community was hit by a large
rc willy truck the guard passed away on
scene
it's not clear yet how this happened
this is not a heavy traffic area but as
you can also see there is a lot of
construction going on
whether that was a factor in the
accident we do not know
earlier henderson police were blocking
people from entering the area
but it has since opened up and you can
see there there's still a lot going on
here
and even earlier in the footage that you
might have seen it was a very very busy
scene so we will keep you posted of
course i'm awaiting on an update from
henderson police but keep it here at
five o'clock
and then also you can check updates
online reporting live in henderson
madison kimbrough 8 news now